هذه الفوضى التي خطفت انفاس العالم عقبا
سحاب الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
افغانستان عام 2021 تعود الى الواجهه
وتلاحق اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بيدر بعد
ان قرر المعسكر الجمهوري صاحب الاكثريه في
مجلس النواب الامريكي فتحه تحقيق برلماني
حول طريقه انسحاب بلادهم من افغانستان
عنها مقتل 13 جنديا امريكيا اداره بيضا
رفضت مرارا طلبات التدقيق وواصلت حجب
المعلومات حول الانسحاب ماذا فعل لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه لمجلس النواب الى الطلب
من خارجيه البلاد تقديم سلسله وثائقه
وتحديدا مذكرات استخباراتيه او رسائل مع
حركه طالبان اللجنه حذرت من انه في حال
الرفض هذه المره فانها تتردد في الانتقال
الى عمليه تلزم اداره بيضا بتقديم الوثائق
الخارجيه الامريكيه لم تعلق رسميا على
المطلب الجمهوري ولكن مصادر قالت انها
قدمت اكثر من مئه وخمسين احاطه لاعضاء
الكونغرس منذ الانسحاب
انسحاب القوات الامريكيه من افغانستان
انها اطول حربها الولايات المتحده وساهمت
بعوده حركه طالبان الى السلطه ووضعت بيضا
بمواجهه انتقادات شديده من قبل الحلفاء
والخصوم
محاسن حضاره العربيه